your two screenplays that you had one
that was
looked at and and scrutinized by john
carpenter the other one that was
ready for production and it fell through
a few days beforehand
what did both those situations teach you
about writing
they just taught you i mean they taught
me to be just
part of the process because you know you
start working with directors and
producers and actors and even though
neither neither of those projects got
made you realize that like
you're not an individual in this process
you have to you have to be a team player
you have to work with all these
different people that have their
their input and maybe producer a has
some good ideas and producer b
has horrible ideas but producer b might
be giving you the money for the film so
it's like
how do you navigate those waters so that
was that was what i took out of those
more than anything it's like
it's not i don't get to do what i want
but i've got to try to like you know
navigate to a sense to where
i can make it what i want or win some of
the battles but i'm not going to win
them all
and you just don't have a choice when
someone pays you for something
they own it you know it's like it's like
if you sold your house and then you're
like
well i don't want them to tear out the
hardwood floors they're going to do it
anyway
so you know a lot of it is is doing that
as being
figuring out how to like navigate those
waters of like to keep the integrity of
your script and still get the movie made
because that's a very
you know delicate balance between the
two
you had been in the film industry before
you said were you working as a script
reader or around script readers
no i actually had worked at um
streamlined pictures which was the
company that brought all the anime
over to america in the 90s i worked for
carl masik and how i got that job was i
got out of college
i played in a band and the drummer had
gotten a job there marketing and i was
like i need a job so he goes i'll get
you one so
he got me a job there and it was a
really interesting
environment because streamline was like
did so many things they produced films
they
they imported films they created content
they they were like really ahead of the
game in a lot of ways
and carl masik was like probably the
first mentor i ever had he passed away a
few years ago but he was a great guy
and just kind of let us do our own thing
he'd be like
call universal and see if we can set up
this film well how just figure it out
you know so you just be left your own
devices so from that
working at that company i learned a lot
about films and and the industry
and the business part which i think is
still an advantage i have over a lot of
other people in the film industry that
i understand how the the money works and
where it flows back and forth and
and what's the bottom line of making a
film
so from there i worked on some indie
films i produced some indie films
after that and you know some commercials
some music videos and
you know just learned about production
as much as i could and didn't
even on the indie films i worked on i
didn't just sit in a chair i i sat there
with a line producer and learned how to
you know
line by line how to budget a film how to
do all that stuff
because it was just like if i'm going to
do this for a living i need to know as
much as i can
about everything every department so
that's pretty much what i took away from
that
is that something that you think is to
your advantage i mean have you always
been that way where you cut you
you don't you you just need to be told
where point b
is or a is and you'll find a way out
again yeah i i'm a little bit in both
right brain and left brain so i can i'm
one of those few people that can like
do a budget but i can also write a
script
you know there's not a lot of people
like that so i don't know why i can do
that but
it's it's you know you you when you
understand
the business points of like why people
are investing two three million dollars
in a film
and what they want out of it it becomes
a little bit easier to shape the
creative side too
hope that hell it did
what would you say to people that say
well i only do this though i mean i mean
some people think that you know what it
was it um
jack of all trades master of none and
they don't they don't want to get
in in that situation but then there's a
real um
power in knowing how many different
things work yeah
and and and here's the thing this is
what i always try to the the more you
know about the film business
the better it's going to help you you
don't have to be an expert but you have
to kind of understand how things work
because this is the one thing i always i
always try to explain to people
that are want to get into screenwriting
they'll be like
hey i wrote this script it's my first
script i want to get it out to producers
i want to send it to people i want to
get it made and they want someone who
they don't know
who's who they've never made money for
to give them two million dollars
now if you just take that aside and you
think
that you want to start a restaurant but
you've never worked one day in a
restaurant you've never
even been in the kitchen of a restaurant
and you write a business plan for a
restaurant
and you go to somebody who invests in
restaurants and say can i have two
million dollars for this restaurant
they're gonna think you're crazy but for
some reason screenwriters think oh i
wrote the script someone should give me
two million dollars
it's yet it's their first script it's
their first business plan they haven't
spent any time in the industry
and think somebody's gonna write a check
for two million dollars because it's
that good
i mean maybe there are a couple scripts
they're that good that people just gonna
throw millions of dollars at you but
there's like that's like a handful
on the planet so people don't understand
it's like that's
one of the things that like i try to
instill in people is like if you want to
be a screen
screenwriter and do it professionally
you maybe your sixth or seventh will be
good enough to show to a producer your
first script about your uncle isn't
going anywhere
you know and there's millions of those
and
that's the problem is like it's not hard
to become professional screenwriter but
you have to do the work
and you have to understand the business
that's what people don't do a lot of
times
and is there a hazing with all the
knocks that you're going to get and all
the
stuff that's going to be the plug's
going to be pulled and then
yeah you have to have very very thick
skin and something that took me a long
time to understand too is you have to
interpret notes
because sometimes producers don't like
something but they can't
tell you what they don't like so they
say no a
and it kind of doesn't make sense you
have to figure it out you have no
guideline because
there's i've worked with both kinds of
producers really fantastic a-list
producers and other ones that are good
at like
putting a film together but can't
articulate the creative side
so you have to figure out what they
don't like
and that's your job and you know that
sometimes
it's just alchemy you're like you got to
get inside their head and understand why
they don't like
the first act and when we hear about
these
wunderkind or whatever that's like their
first thing and then it's picked up and
it's probably more so maybe in the past
i don't know
how much does that spoil us as writers
or creatives because we think oh
i'm going to be the next one yeah it
does i mean it does because
those stories get told over and over but
they're so
few and far between i know a lot of
filmmakers i know a lot of directors i
know a lot of
writers and there's very few films that
completely change your life
it's more like a stepping stone from
this to this like maybe you'll do this
movie and then you'll get that one
you'll direct a bigger move
you went from directing a million dollar
movie to 5 million to 30. but
there are those things where people get
hit by lightning you know but
i always try to say that 50 of of
getting a project put together is super
hard work being talented
staying focused and the other 50 is
timing and luck
because the market can change you know
within minutes
because we had a script that was this
thriller that people liked
we put it on the market and we had some
people really interested in it and then
taking came out like two weeks later and
then suddenly
my agent got like 20 calls like the next
morning
hey you know that and it wasn't really
even like taken but it just
was like a revenge thriller and it's
like so suddenly the script that
everybody's kind of into
becomes everybody's into because
something was a hit
so you can't control that you can't
control the market you have to just do
the best work and hope that
you know it goes somewhere sure it found
footage
you know yeah yeah yeah things change so
something you wrote
even now like i've had people like talk
to me about like older scripts like hey
what about that and i'm like
i don't even want to send it to you
because i feel like a i'm a better
writer and b
things have changed it's just that was
written 12 years ago it's not the same
kind of
way movies are made because things do
evolve
you